okay so I did a video with a big
exclusive update about Star Trek but I
did it outside in North Wales with the
Wind
no one could hear me
so here is take two
Big Star Trek exclusive news
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so we're speaking today with a chap I
know who works closely with Paramount he
has been able to feed me some very
exclusive news that actually Paramount
are seriously considering a new Terry
metallis showrun TV show based on Star
Trek potentially his Star Trek Legacy TV
show that he's been talking about quite
a lot in interviews recently now
parents are not massively excited or
haven't been massively excited about
continuing their relationship with Alex
kurtzman and secret hideout Who
currently produce Star Trek even as Star
Trek Picard season 3 started they were
not massively excited about it mainly
because very early on in the series The
Numbers the viewing figures weren't
great but as the series has developed
it's found its audience it's been
regularly number one and the Paramount
pluses top 10 list the viewing figures
have been very good and are only growing
this is given Parliament a little bit of
confidence to continue their
relationship with secret hideout on the
understanding
the kurtzman
who has been responsible for some of the
Star Trek we haven't liked so much is
not involved creatively and Terry
matalis showruns now it is fair to say
that actually Parliament have been quite
happy with a lot of the Star Trek that's
been produced by secret hideout that
Terry metallis has done and other
producers and Alex kurtzman has kept
creatively away from they're very happy
with lodex they're very happy with
Prodigy they're very happy with strange
new world they're very happy with season
three of Picard
so it seems that the growing confidence
in Picard season 3 has allowed Terry
matalis to create a show now this is
very very early on in the conversation
and it would seem that from the
conversation I'm having with the guy I
speak to that this show will be based
around potentially this um Star Trek
Legacy idea that terminals have been
talking about that's mean it would
involve some of the kids from of the TMG
you know stars that we've seen in Picard
season three so Jack Crusher laforge's
kid and maybe a couple of others who
knows and this also might mean that
people like Picard would return and
Patrick Stewart has already kind of
hinted at that I'd love to see Jonathan
Frank's return he's almost certainly
going to be directing it and God knows
whoever else you know I've I've seen
Marina certis against McFadden et cetera
Etc already talking about that if enough
fans want this they will return for some
unnamed project now for a while
Paramount we're not very excited about
that idea but my source is telling me
that our conversations that happened
literally yesterday might mean that
those doubts have gone away
now as I say this is very very early on
but if it happens it could be very very
exciting news so the Star Trek
potentially Legacy series could also
from what I'm hearing be based aboard
the Titan
on one hand I think that's great I'd
love to see Captain Shaw return if he
survives the series I'd love to see
Captain Shaw return
I don't think he's going to but let's
see
but a seven of nine is captain of the
Titan with a few of these characters
like Jack Crusher and leforge's kid
aboard that ship
a Star Trek Legacy yeah why not there's
a other idea that I've had
there's going to be a new Enterprise
is already quite surprisingly basically
told us that the Enterprise is going to
get multiple and scrapped The Odyssey
class that we've been so excited to see
we're only going to see it for a few
seconds in probably the final episode of
Picard season three
so that means there's going to be a new
Enterprise
so Star Trek Legacy aboard a new
Enterprise wouldn't that make more sense
but I'd love you guys to get into the
comments and tell me what you think
about that idea because to me it's clear
Paramount we're not massively excited
about a new Star Trek project and they
were very clearly going to be slowing
down production of any new series we've
already seen that Discovery has been
pushed back Strange New World season two
has been pushed back
there is definitely 100 not going to be
Five Star Trek series moving forwards
only maybe a maximum of four and I'm
here and maybe only three so between
lower decks and Prodigy I think one of
those shows might be in trouble but
we'll see what happens in the next year
or two also I should tell you that this
new series will probably not actually be
announced until
um Strange New World season two is aired
so we're looking at oh maybe towards the
end of the year early next year and then
it will potentially Premiere the
following year so we'd be looking at
early 2020 oh 2025 maybe late 2024 we'll
have to see what happens
again paramounts have been pushing back
and stretching out the schedule of
strange new worlds Discovery season five
very much on purpose to make sure that
it wasn't too obvious that they were
slowing down the production of current
Star Trek
and that they were very clearly going to
be spending less money on Star Trek so
do not expect a budget of 10 million
quid like
um card season three got it's going to
be a much lower budget a lot of stars
have come back to the show and they've
uh expected quite a lot of money just as
a final little thing I'm also hearing
that this really is the last nail in the
coffin of any idea that kurtzman had of
making section 31 or Star Trek bloody
90210 Starfleet Academy that's been
bound and round for so long neither of
these projects are going to happen
they're going to be going with Terry
matalis
but guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think is this a project you're
excited by or would you like to see
something else and what do you think
about my Star Trek the Enterprise idea
come on the Odyssey class is going we're
getting a new Enterprise why not build a
series on that it's a no-brainer right
I'd love to know though exactly what you
think if you're new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and you
will never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first
as always please stay safe and aren't
you glad I decided to do a video indoors
I'll see you next time foreign
[Music]